good morning belief nation today's
message is write it all down so the most
important thing you can do is plan your
day preferably the night before sit down
with a piece of paper and write down
everything that you have to do the
coming day it should be the last thing
you do at the end of the day now if for
any reason you don't do this then the
first thing you do in the morning before
you check your email your phone calls
newspapers first thing you do in the
morning is make a list of everything
that you have to do that day once you
have a list you have a track to run on
writing down a list clarifies your
thinking writing down a list forces you
to think at a higher level if you are
working from a list you increase your
productivity and output by 25% the first
day all successful people work from
lists and all successful people with
regard to their projects were from check
lists a checklist is a list of
everything organized in sequence and you
go down the checklist so what do you
think I think you should definitely
write it all down
I believe words make a real if you write
things down in your journal make it look
things too
you'll make things happen so write it
all down I think for me I like writing
as a way to just cement ideas it helps
me think yeah you don't forget stuff
yeah whether I'm writing it sometimes I
find it like paper more and sometimes I
find I want to write on my on my my
tablet or the computer I kind of weird
that way
me too I'm the same I love writing to
pen and paper and then I love like
rethinking on my journal on on my
computer I I find that if I don't write
something down I'm gonna forget it I
have a terrible memory if it's not on my
email I won't get it done so I've been
meeting with Microsoft for the past
couple days and any time I get night the
air or to do I got it I got a set myself
a book email and write it down because
otherwise it's gone I'm gonna forget a
whole bunch of stuff I agree and you get
that creative inspiration you just got
to go for it go write it down it's silly
if it is minute school you'll come back
to it later write it down so the
question of the day today is what's your
favorite place to write things down on
oh your favorite place like all that
computer yeah god I was taking places to
meet left that was a curveball a coffee
shop or something option a physical
location option B where are you actually
writing it down leave it in the comments
below
we're both meandering discussion thank
you guys so much for watching have an
amazing day continue to believe and
we'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of espresso
that makes them some good video
beep-beep-beep we're gonna get filtered
out of the channel okay you gotta punch
the camera okay